ça va peut-être être le test le plus
rapide du monde
opale aujourd'hui du samsung galaxy note
10 plus et se note 10 plus il a un seul
intérêt un seul vrai intérêt si vous
voulez acheter un smartphone de samsung
c'est le s pen
si vous ne vous intéressez pas aux
appels il n'y a strictement aucun
intérêt à venir acheter le galaxy note
10 plus jeunes explique pourquoi je vous
dit où vous allez voir c'est extrêmement
simple
[Musique]
non
en début d'année les vies 2019 samsung
est arrivé avec des nouveaux smartphones
vraiment excellent que sont les samsung
galaxy s 10 et se disent plus des
smartphones sont toujours très actuel
très bon très performant aussi bien au
niveau de l'écran au niveau du design
encore plus à une encoche la bulle je
suis un peu moins fans surtout sur la
i10 plus c'est gros ce double bulle je
suis un petit peu moyen dessus mais par
contre ce qui est vraiment générique ce
smartphone c'est l'écran est magnifique
les appareils photos sont magnifiques
les rangs du son très juste très bon et
marche à la perfection
si vous voulez du grand format le dise
plus marche très bien et très bon et
justement pourrait se dire eh bien ils
sont un peu proche de ses notes 10 ans
revient toujours être la gamme s et la
gamme note bon mais ce qui faisait la
d27 gamme note c'est le côté fable est
le côté fabless vous l'avez de plus en
plus lourde et que les smartphones
actuels qui ont beaucoup de 6,4 pousse à
tel point que samsung a été obligé de
réagir sur la gamme dont le sortant un
smartphone un peu plus petit qu'elle
note 10 et un peu plus grands kg 10
puces avec le 6,8 pousseur du coup moi
j'ai voulu tester le plus grand modèle
qui me semble être le plus intéressant
le plus petit modèle c'est en gros
l'équivalent nos smartphones actuels
avec un aspect d' un stylet pas plus pas
moins et toutes les fonctionnalités dont
je vous ai parlé toute la qualité de
l'appareil
donc si vous voulez rester dans la
dérive en tout cas de la gamme note
c'est celui là le note 10 plus est avec
le côté fable est 6,8 pouces qui est
très grand peut-être des fois un peu
gros il faut l'utiliser très clairement
à demain une seule main je vois pas du
tout l'intérêt vous allez galères et
vous allez partir à prendre le risque de
le faire tomber
ça serait relativement bas l'eau donc
l'idée de ce smartphone si vous voulez
reste en tout cas dans l'idée de la
gamme note c'est le 6,10 poussé le note
10 plus et c'est surtout le style et
parce que quel intérêt en transe 6 3 6 4
pouces et 6,8 pouces si ce n'est au
final l'idée de la tablette l'idée
du style et avec les belles innovations
et toutes les avancées qu'on a cette
année je vais quand même vous parler de
ce smartphone globalement mais je vous
dis le vrai intérêt lors elle acquérait
tu ne dises plus réside dans son style
et dac les nouveaux gestes qui sont
disponibles avec tout ce que vous allez
pouvoir en faire parce que l'eau reste
est très bon mais comme pouvait être
également un ace dispute ya pas très
longtemps je vous ferai pas l'affront de
parler de la boîte parce qu'on en a déjà
parlé lors de leur beau xing dont l alma
dans le coin elle bouge pas par contre
je vais vous parler de cette petite bête
cette petite bête qui est franchement
très sympa alors ce que j'aime et ce que
je conseille toujours là dessus c'est
effectivement de choisir un fond d'écran
qui va dire cacher la caméra là ça
marchera toujours bien en tout cas mieux
parce que voilà je trouve que
effectivement samsung mais très très
bons et excellents 2019
on a les bulles on a les encoches on a
les petits trous percés 2020 je pense
que ça va disparaître avec la gamme s en
tout cas qui va arriver début de 2020
donc ça s'arrête intéressant va suivre
ça de très près dont je vous invite dès
maintenant à vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas par contre ce smartphone
là il est tout simplement excellent la
prise en main est bonne alors attention
c'est un très très grand format très
grand écran comme je le disais 6,8
pousse donc ça se bastonne que vous
allez utiliser à demain si vous
l'utilisez à une seulement soit vous
êtes des énormes paluches soit vous êtes
vraiment un cascadeur et vous craignez
pas de lefa tomber d'ailleurs je vous
conseille vraiment de protéger déjà pour
moi il ya deux intérêts principaux déjà
ce smartphone même s'il est très très
beau vous avez ce dos un petit work
ancien c'est aussi un gros dos traces de
doigts que de leur côté un peu sale tout
de suite alors effectivement quand on
regarde dans les review eh bien il est
beau il brille il est sympa et on dit
ouah je veux ce dos il est magnifique
mais la réalité c'est qu'au final vous
avez traces de gras d'oie un petit peu
partout il a un côté très sale assez
dégueu et c'est tout c'est un petit peu
embêtant lors dans un musée je pense
qu'il sera vraiment magnifique
mais pour l'utilisation courante cole
qui sont communes eh bien voyez ça c'est
un petit peu un petit peu dommage par
contre fait vraiment garde parce qu'un
smartphone comme ça même si les protégés
même s'il est bon il faut le protéger je
vous conseille vraiment de mettre une
coque et d'ailleurs vous savez j'ai un
partenariat avec ritchie salut toi j'ai
des coques à vous proposer et moi ce que
j'aime beaucoup ses salariés à ses sept
sollicite la garde et que je trouve
la très jolie très sympa très efficace
vous la prenez vous mettez dedans ça
vous le protège complètement ça vient
complètement l'intégrer ça vous protège
de tous les côtés sur la face avant
sur la face arrière il craint plus rien
et quand même sortir facilement votre
style et sa ses côtés vraiment
extrêmement pratique donc je ne peux que
vous recommander vous avez moins 10% que
j'ai mis le code en bas dans la
description a déjà un petit coup d'oeil
et franchement ce smartphone
même si les bordelais arrière je vous
conseille vraiment mais vraiment
vraiment plus plus plus de le protéger
de mettre une coque de protection il ya
vraiment un côté glissant avec ce
smartphone simple une savonnette faut
quand même faire super supérieur alors
une fois de plus je vous dis la prise en
main moi je trouve bien le smartphone
j'aime bien ce que j'aime beaucoup
vraiment c'est le travail qui est fait
au niveau des finitions regard des
voisins les courbes sont vraiment belles
je trouve vraiment qu'il ya encore une
fois de plus un excellent boulot une
grosse grosse grosse grosse maîtrise de
la part de samsung sur le design de ses
produits très très beau très bien fait
superbe écran je vous en parle dans
quelques instants c'est vraiment un
excellent produit
la prise en main et hop en plus avaient
eu capteurs ultrasoniques qui se trouve
juste là sur la face avant on pose son
doigt et déverrouille extrêmement
rapidement le seul truc que je pourrais
reprocher mais je pense que c'est une
habitude
si vous avez deux boutons pour l'allumer
qui situe ici sur la gauche et non pas
sur la droite moi j'ai toujours cherché
avec mon pouce là et je suis un peu
frustré ici vous n'avez absolument rien
il faut bien chercher ici avec le majeur
ou avec l'index en fonction de votre
doigt fonction de votre main une fois
que vous l'avez ça marche bien mais
voilà c'est une question d'habitude
et moi en tout cas ça ne rentrent pas
dans mes habitudes alors justement vous
parlez de cet écran vous avez à l'écran
de 6 et 1 8 pouces de diagonale
moi je trouve vraiment bien les angles
visionnages sont vraiment cool que vous
le métier d'un côté ou de l'autre il en
plus d'une possibilité pour venir
complètement le personnaliser votre
écran en fonction de ce que vous allez
vouloir faire en tout cas d'aig vous
allez dans affichage résolution l'écran
vous pouvez soit laissé en eiffage des
plus communes et la 2280 par 1080 pixels
soit en plus est des plus 3040 par 1440
moi je trouve ça bien c'est une
possibilité de le faire par contre je
trouve que dans l'absolu ça ne change
pas grand chose pareille de mode vif
naturel rester sur le mode naturel c'est
ce qui est beaucoup plus jolie
c'est vraiment parfait et je vous dis je
suis un peu frustré parce que je trouve
que ce soit côté qhd plus c'est bien
puis ça me transcende pas le seul truc
que je vais regretter un petit peu c'est
qu'on est un écran qui soit pas en 90
airbus pourrait l'être mais là non il
n'est pas donc c'est bien de mettre du
pillage des plus mais je trouve que ce
serait encore mieux d'être avec
lire ci dessus est là pour coup sûr un
vrai sens par contre la qualité de ce
smartphone est vraiment bien les
couleurs respecter naturel c'est beau ça
marche vraiment bien les contrastes
magnifique les noirs infi lycée l'oled
c'est normal c'est maîtrisé en plus de
ça je trouve extrêmement lumineux pour
l'utiliser en extérieur il n'y a pas de
souci l'écran est compatible hd r10 plus
donc si vous utilisez des plateformes
qui ont dû agir 10 plus vous allez vous
régaler la température des couleurs est
bien et en plus ce qui est top
ça gâche vraiment pas l'histoire c'est
la réduction des lumières bleues qui
fait grâce à cet écran dont vous allez
pas vous flinguer les yeux vous avez
pour moi un excellent écran que ce n'est
pas un des meilleurs écrans du marché je
trouve vraiment agréable pour me
regarder du contenu je vous dis ce que
je regrette un petit peu c'est le
poinçon sans le côté à côté de ça on
oublie quand même assez rapidement au
temps qui écoule ses l'audio vous avez
des hauts parleurs stéréo vous avez de
la puissance audio écoutez moi ça le
fond est fort très très fort ça craint
vraiment cool l'expérience sonore mars
quand même plutôt bien l'autre qu'on
progresse et qu'il n'y a plus de prise
jack
ni ici ni si vous êtes donc devoir vous
contenter d'utiliser soit un casque
bluetooth soit branché un petit casque
en usb c'est bon franchement je vous
recommande aux casques bleus tout je
prenais le galaxy veulent par exemple
qui marche très bien qu'ils sont très
bien on a eu plein casque en bluetooth
ray du fonds bruit ou pas qui sont
vraiment cool côté performances se
trouve aussi excellent avec son exil aux
9825 couplé à 12 giga de ram
vous pouvez pas le mettre à genoux qui
marche bien on sera pas aussi performant
qu'un sa dragonne 855 plus mais il fera
parfaitement la ferme on joue à plein de
jeux qu elle soit 9 ici ça marche
parfaitement bien n'aura pas du tout de
problème
et en plus à l'intérieur vous avez une
grosse batterie de 4300 milles et hop
erreurs et attention grand écran qui est
surtout consommé davantage grosse
batterie 4300 milles intérieur je trouve
quelques tout est assez bien optimisé
pour moi c'est un smartphone qui est
quand même relativement durant pour le
garder deux jours bien évidemment ça
dépend de votre utilisation savez pas ce
que vous allez en faire
néanmoins sur l'utilisation je dirais un
peu standard courante ça marchera
n'aurait pas de problème gros gros gros
point positif on plus vous avez un
chargeur de 25 watts qui est inclus à
l'intérieur vous le recharger rapidement
vous rechargez à 100 % en une heure donc
ça c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment cool
et en plus de ça bien évidemment vous
avez de la recharge inversée pourrait
donc recharger nos smartphones dépanner
un pote charger vos veines avec le fait
qu'il vachement cool et si vous voulez
aller encore plus vite etc là vous avez
vraiment con ça carbure
et bien vous pouvez acheter en option à
un chargeur de 45 watts et là par contre
carrément c'est l'autoroute est ouest où
elle et on ne s'arrête pas je passe trè
finement sur manuel qu'on connaît qui
marche parfaitement bien vous avez plein
d'options sont très rapides vous pouvez
trouver plein de choses ici tout ça
vraiment bien c'est hyper hyper hyper
hyper optimisé vous avez un mode nuit
qui est vraiment cool
vous allez donc pouvoir aller dans vos
paramètres utilisés en mode forza les
dunes économiser de la batterie parce
que tout ce qui va être noir sont des
pixels et un don qui ne concerne
absolument pas d'énergie bon - nuages
vous le savez on a déjà parlé c'est une
des meilleures expériences android c'est
vraiment top ne serait-ce qu'au niveau
des raccourcis moi j'aimais ici la
navigation par geste pouvait remettre
votre barre de navigation en cliquant
juste là directement ici c'est vraiment
cool pratique accès à l'espace enfants
vous avez bien évidemment les airs
action du s p ne semblant pas dans
quelques instants
vous avez quasiment tout ici moi je
trouve ça vraiment bien je vous disais
encore bull pour moi ce smartphone il
existe parce que il y a le s pen est
l'intérêt de ce smartphone réside au
niveau du spn s'il n'y avait pas le
respect le note mais pas trop
d'intérieur c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
comme je vous le disais le format fable
est le format grand écran il y en a
partout on a de plus en plus des 6,4
poussa inondent le marché donc bon je
vois pas trop l'intérêt de se dire
pourquoi est ce que j'irai sur 1 6 3 6 4
pouces de chez samsung sur la gamme note
s'il n'y avait pas sur l'espagne vient
justement ce espagne il est magique
à quelque chose près et surtout il ya de
belles innovations d'année en année
l'ania lien pouvait déclencher des
photos à distance grâce à la connexion
bluetooth entre le s pen et votre
smartphone pré s'était déjà vachement
bien mais là il va encore plus loin avec
les aides gesture valera qui est
vraiment temps voyez par exemple la
double clic
hop je change d'appareil photo ça me met
sur l'arrière salle mais sur l'avant je
peux changer de mode
j'appuie je navigue comme ça je change
de mode vidéo vidéo mode portrait hyper
l'aps d'un côté de l'ogs voyez je fais
ce que je veux c'est vachement pratique
et sousse a vraiment vraiment cool et
aussi à moi qui est vraiment génial vous
prenez votre espen vous l'enlevez vous
n'allumez pas votre smartphone et vous
venez écrire dessus alors bon moi
j'écris mal donc ça va être vite vu
j'écris un petit coucou avec un joli
petit coeur voyez hop je le prends je le
remets ici je le pose et paf s'est
enregistré directement ma note est dans
la boîte
ensuite je peux a loupé mon smartphone
je vais dans mes notes et la voyez je
retrouve les notes que j'ai déjà créé
qui sont là qui sont sympas qui sont
belles j'ai mon petit coucou toi qui est
très sympa a par exemple j'écris
extrêmement mal non
comment vouloir on va écrire que mon ami
je vais cliquez ici là juste en bas et
il va reconnaître mon texte alors des
fois c'est pas parfait sa dépendance
écriture coucou mon âme est ce à dire ça
dépend vraiment de vous envoyer maman il
n'est pas très y on va recommencer
coucou mon ami ensuite je viens cliquez
juste ici en dessous et là il reconnaît
mon texte coucou mon ami pourra c'est
vachement bien ensuite je peux le
convertir l'utiliser voyez je peux
utiliser pour travailler sur la prise de
notes manuscrites comme ça c'est
vraiment top
j'ai appris plein d'autres possibilités
faire des captures d'écran des messages
ali mais qu'est ce qu'un peu nouveau
scellé ailleurs google ça c'est assez
marrant on va prendre un exemple avec
donald je vais là je vais dans ar
doodles on va faire un petit dessin
dessus et vous allez voir c'est assez
rigolo on va lui faire des petites
lunettes
alors bon je dessine mal je tremble dans
tous les cas c'est pas hyper simple et
voyez lorsque j'ai eu bouger la figurine
de donald les lunettes vont bouger comme
ça également de la même manière dont ça
c'est assez marrant ces gadgets mais bon
pourquoi pas l'idée en fait c'est qu'ils
ont installé un accéléromètre et un
gyroscope là dedans qui m'a donc
reconnaître les mouvements la force de
frappe en bas sur ce smartphone et je
dis une fois de plus c'est ça cette
petite arme c'est le style et qui
progresse qui s'équipent de plus en plus
envie de faire plein de choses
maintenant la question à se poser c'est
est-ce que vous avez besoin de ce style
est est ce que vous avez un usage sur ce
style et si ce n'est le côté arrière
noodle dessinée c'est marrant si ce
n'est les gestes c'est marrant mais tout
ça ça reste du gadget dès lors qu'on a
besoin du stylet ce stylet vous servira
pour de la prise de notes vous pouvoir
convertir derrière en texte vous avez
une idée paf vous le faites sont de la
retouche photo pourquoi pas c'est
extrêmement millimétré c'est très
calibrée pour une fois ça c'est assez
marrant il ya plein d'usagé avec mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que avant de vouloir
acheter ce produit il faut être sûr de
ses usages son style et sinon je
conseille quand même de switcher sur un
ace 10 plus qui sera vraiment tout
autant excellent que ces petites bêtes
là j'ai pas grand chose de neuf du côté
de la photo par rapport à ce qu'on
pouvait avoir sur un ace 10 plus on va
avoir sensiblement la même chose juste
couverture qui va changer un petit peu
vous avez quatre capteurs 3 ici et un
ici en gros vous allez avoir un capteur
principal de 12 mégapixels savait qu est
la fameuse ouverture variable f1 points
5 f 2.4 luttera grand-angle de 16
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.2 un
téléobjectif fois deux parfois trois
mais fois de 12 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.1 et puis la petite caméra tough qui
cache est juste là times of light qui
servent pour les faits évoqués pour le
mode portrait et notamment ce qui est un
peu nouveau
pour le mode portrait en vidéo le mode
portrait en vidéo pour moi sa sortie ça
vraiment absolument à rien autant en
photo ça marche bien ça vient apporter
effectivement sous le feu derrière plan
autant ce qu'au niveau de la vidéo et à
côté un petit peu what the fuck et mon
avis il faut complètement oublié par
contre l'appareil photo est toujours
aussi bon très juste des photos qui sont
légèrement saturé mais pas trop on a un
bon pique et je trouve que ça marche
vraiment bien là vous êtes sur la caméra
principale mais vous x 2 s'est
parfaitement bien maîtrisée elle
s'illustra grand donc je trouve que les
couleurs sont vraiment maîtrisée dont on
passe d'une photo à l'autre pour voir
qu'on n'est pas du tout sur le même
capteur ça marche ici on est sur
l'appareil photo principale le zoom x de
l'ultra grand angle ça marche vraiment
bien pareil photo normale une fois 2 et
du très grand angle au niveau du self si
vous avez une caméra ici caché bien
évidemment vous avez vu de 10 mégapixels
mais je trouve que le rendu est
franchement honnête je vous montre le
côté photo nuit même si pour moi c'est
pas le meilleur appareil pour faire des
photos nues et ça c'est plutôt j'ai
prise dans l'obscurité en mode normal
voit ce que ça donne et quand je switche
sur le mode photo nuit ça éclaircit
vachement c'est pas idéal mais ça marche
pas trop mal avec le zoom x 2 et avec
l'ultra grand ensemble
bon c'est pas ouf mais ça fonctionne on
l'a ce qui se fait mieux là dessus on a
même du wifi six ans maintenant que je
trouve vraiment très bien et que vous
pouvez trouver en deux configurations
256 go 512 il ya de stockage pour les
deux versions extensible sur ce modèle
là parce que sur le galaxy note d'ici
n'est pas extensible il faut arriver sûr
le note 10 plus pour qu'elle soit
extensible vous trouvez le 256 giga à
1109 euros et le 512 ziga à 1209 euros
et c'est justement là qu'il faut
commencer un petit peu à mouliner à
réfléchir parce que je vous le dis on
laissera smartphones qui est quand même
extrêmement prenium du très haut de
gamme mais aussi très cher et la vraie
différence une fois de plus et je le dis
je le répète et je le ramasse mais c'est
vraiment ça elle se fait dans cette
petite chose là sur ce petit stylet qui
vient se ranger ici si vous n'avez pas
réellement besoin de ce style est allé
sur le galaxy s 10 plus qui sera moins
cher très bon d'excellente facture ou
alors pourquoi pas sur le x10 à vous de
voir mais évidemment en fonction de vos
usages les joueurs une fois de plus nos
10 + moi je trouve très bon très bien
très aboutie très actuelle est au top
extrêmement maîtrisé quelques poids
encore qu'on pour améliorer notamment
sur le jeudi le taux de rafraîchissement
de l'image me promener sur 1,80 d'hier
ça pourrait vraiment avoir un sens on
n'est pas loin de là
perfection mais une fois de plus un
produit comme ça il doit correspondre à
vos usages pour être sûr que vous aurez
besoin notamment de ce style et et c'est
là vraiment que ce fait tout l'intérêt
de ce smartphone
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire comment vous le
trouver est ce que vous le trouver
intéressant ce galaxy note 10 plus est
ce que vous vous avez switcher pour
l'instant ne disent plus ou alors est-ce
que vous avez un ace 10 16 bis plus de
cette année et au final vous dites moi
ce que je vois pas trop l'intérêt
d'aller là dessus ou alors est-ce que
vous avez un modèle antérieur
note 9 pourquoi pas qui au final est
très bon très actuel et quelques
fonctionnalités que vous n'aurez pas en
plus notamment les gestes mais par
contre pouvez quand même prendre des
photos à distance car cette petite
télécommande là vous pouvez commander
votre powerpoint ya pas mal de choses
donc tout ça plutôt bien pour moi c'est
un accessoire qui se destinent pro et
semi pro je dirais quand même aux
personnes qui ont besoin de prise de
notes rapides qui ont besoin de
communiquer rapidement que le petit
stylet pris de notes qui veulent prendre
des idées pourquoi pas qu on est plus
sur cette cible là dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en bas et s'il vous tente oui
non quoi comment sur ce je donne rendez
vous dès demain je vous embrasse
et puis n'oubliez pas si vous voulez
venir monde de la chaîne vous pouvez le
faire vous avez le bouton rejoindre
juste en dessous ça c'est vachement cool
mon bisous et à demain ciao